foreign
and talk to Brett what is up Brett
hey John how you doing oh good I thought
this was Brett Favre and so good
I was actually named after him of course
but never played football I just assumed
85 percent of Wisconsin is walking
around named Brett at some point
followed by Aaron is the other name
yeah yeah so what's up dude
um so I have a question for you
um how do I rebuild a solid relationship
with my family after losing trust with
them in the past what'd you do
here uh right before Before Christmas
actually I went through kind of a
breakup you know it was
um kind of kind of somewhat my fault I
was a little bit of like you know a
closet drinker in a way
um and um so there was like no trust so
it was kind of like uh
um
kind of like okay I understood but I
I've never really been good with dealing
with my emotions so
um I just kind of led to drinking a lot
um but the big thing that happened was
uh
um I ended up going on like a week and a
half long Bender uh in front of my
family
and uh it just it's something I'm
ashamed of and you know they tell me
they love me and and everything but it's
just it's more of like a my problem that
I have a hard time like believing that
um and I was kind of wondering like
should I sit down with them should I
um like it wasn't like cousins or aunts
or uncles it was like parents and
brothers
um what did you did you do some some
things that you regret were you on a
bender
yeah
yeah I'd say so like I was kind of like
swearing in front of my parents which I
never do that
um and like just like I stole their car
you know went to the heart was it lead
with that dude
I had a bender and I stole my parents
car that's where we it's like well I
said some bad words
dude incredible
um yeah no I like honestly um it's been
a few months so I laugh about it now I
guess my dad didn't see it that way
um yeah but I just I wanna be able to
like
um I don't know if I should like sit
down and apologize with them
individually and and all that you know
so I just kind of want to know your
thoughts on that
um
well there's a lot here
and I say there's a lot here because
you didn't just
all of a sudden become a closet drinker
and all of a sudden
not feel safe talking through how you
were feeling about things or being able
to express emotions in a healthy way
yeah and my guess is that same love that
same
like
and well and also you didn't just
overnight become a guy who lied to
somebody that he loved and cared about
about his health and his drinking and
his inability to be in contact with his
emotions or feelings
like that's a long history worth of life
so my question for you would be how much
of this originates in that same family
that saw you come Unwound
um like my parents don't drink at all
that doesn't matter at all in fact that
can sometimes I'll say it make it worse
but
they're they're going to decompress
somehow
and it may have been on you
okay see what I'm saying um do you uh
could you maybe elaborate on that like a
little bit yeah so
let's say your parents didn't drink
let's say they were suit I'm gonna make
something up here okay I don't know
let's say they were super super strict
religious people
and they had a core set of rules
one of which was you never drink
and you never swear
and real people of character and
morality and whatever Faith tradition
fill in fill in your faith tradition of
choice here
people who are
gonna make it in the end don't do this
and this and this and this and this
and then Brett's just a kid
yeah and Brett does a kid thing
and becomes
um
sacrificed on the altar of those seven
or eight or ten or forty different
things that we don't do
we're not allowed to do
and at some point the rules become the
favorite child
the way we are the facade that we wear
is more important
than making sure Brett knows
a brother there is my son there is there
is nothing
you can do that I won't come get you
there is nowhere to go that I won't
still love you
that's not the message the message is
you do these 42 things right then we'll
allow you to sit here
and you know yeah great proxy for
relationship a great proxy for love
chemically speaking is alcohol
uh-huh it is a a young boy's body
screaming for somebody to connect with
me
because my parents are connecting with
their rule set
over me
and so alcohol works man
it works oh yeah I know I believe yeah
so
and then one day you can't hold it in
anymore and it the Dam breaks and the
water bursts forth because you finally
found somebody to plug into
and she left too
yeah no I just made up a whole scenario
just made it up okay any that ring true
or you can be like you're kind of an
idiot no no no no
um I uh I think a lot of it um started
um
when I was probably 18 and like kind of
getting involved in like construction no
no no what happened before that
you you played along before that in what
way
I didn't really like drink no I don't
care about alcohol you're focused on
alcohol I'm not I'm focusing on ways
your body
got to the next day
what were your coping strategies
before alcohol yep
um
or let me say it like this
Straight A's can be a trauma response
too
yeah being I guess um
go ahead
maybe like um I don't know like I always
um
I always like to be the best
you know
um I guess and I always
sometimes maybe like I would try to
please people
I don't know uh
I guess I I can't
um like think of an example of like in
my childhood that I felt
um the need to feel that okay
um but um I mean like we were
um I don't know like things were
um you know that's just how I like to be
you know and yeah I guess I I'm not
really sure you know so let's let's
transition to where we are now
how did you apologize or have you
apologized after what happened at
Christmas
we no and that's that's some yes then
you need you need to get in a car and go
sit with your mom and dad
okay and if you have brothers or sisters
there you need to look across the table
but do not go unless two things are true
number one you have a plan to stop
drinking for good
okay and you are able to demonstrate mom
and dad I don't drink I've been going to
this these meetings I've been seeing
this counselor I got in over my head and
I became somebody I was not
here are the steps I have taken
and not because you're going to love me
more
but I need you all to know that your
little boy's gonna be okay
that's number one number two
don't go apologize until you mean it and
what I mean is don't go apologize to
make yourself feel less guilty because
then you're using them for to prop you
up don't do that
okay go apologize to them because you
hurt them
and yeah you're gonna feel sad and
you're gonna feel very sorry and you're
gonna feel disconnected and that's all
right it's good
because you are
you messed up
yeah
um yeah no I I appreciate that so I that
helps out a lot the third thing I want
you to do here is I don't want you to
try to solve it for them
I want you to ask them
Mom Dad brother sister I love you
and I'm open to whatever it takes to
make this right
and this is submission this is you
taking a knee
and that's going to be hard for you
because you're going to think well what
if they tell me this or what if they say
I can never yep
it's part of restoring relationships and
if they give you something and they say
we want you to do this this and this and
you're like I ain't doing that cool then
you are choosing to walk away from this
relationship I don't think that's your
heart I don't think that's where you are
no no definitely not I that it was
actually like the one
um kind of it was kind of like the one
thing that like the one way I was that
I'd never like wanted my parents to ever
see me like you know blacked out drunk
you know and like do things like that
and you know like saying things in front
of my brother that I really didn't you
know like kind of an example like I was
my brother doesn't really call me a lot
and I was like in front of them and he
was kind of telling me like
um you know we love you and stuff and I
was like oh you never call me you never
do any of this and I I think he kind of
felt bad but I didn't really wanna
I didn't know if I needed to like tell
him that way you know what I mean so
um yeah I think it's as simple as
telling some folks
I got real real drunk and I did some
things and said some things that are
gonna haunt me for the rest of my life I
need you to look you all in the eye and
tell you I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I hurt the people that love me the most
okay and I had a problem with alcohol
here's the steps I'm taking
I had a problem with lying and
dishonesty here's the steps I'm taking
from this point forward here's who I am
going to be
not here's who I'm not here's who I am
and then just know that any one of them
could say yeah screw you
they probably won't
but if you've ever listened to the show
you know I always say every relationship
is a risk everyone is a risk so when you
go to repair a relationship after you've
hurt somebody
I can say I don't I'm I'm done you broke
the circle I'm out
and they get to do that and it's gonna
hurt
but at least at the end of it all you
did the right thing
you you retained dignity and respect
even after doing things that were not
dignified and was not honoring of people
you did the next right thing
then you took a knee and said I hope
you'll still love me my guess is they're
gonna say thank God we do
this is part of growing up and it's the
worst part man
but in person go make the visit
don't do this on the phone don't do this
via text
if you gotta fly pay for the ticket on
your own and go fly
it's time to make this right